First up,
please welcome two students
at Marjory Stoneman Douglas High
in Parkland, Florida,
who co-founded the
advocacy group on gun control,
Never Again MSD, David Hogg
and Cameron Kasky.
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
Hey.
How you doing?
Pleasure.
Great to meet you.
How are you, David?
All right!
Wow.
How you guys doing?
You..
-Tired.
-Tired, yeah.
You're running around
the country doing a good job.
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
Trying to make our voices heard.
Oh, you're doing that and more,
I mean,
you've done a great thing in
turning your grief
into something positive.
And you have a march?
First,
let's just talk about that.
I mean, the future and what's
gonna happen with this movement.
It's on-- It's-- When is it?
It's scheduled for Washington?
It's March 24th.
BILL: Okay.
A march in March on the 24th.
And what are the goals?
Well, we are...
With the march we want Americans
to stop being afraid
of demanding our politicians
to take action.
They work for us,
we don't work for them.
-And the march is us--
-(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
The-- The march is us coming out
and saying to our employees,
"You guys suck at your job."
-BILL: Right. (LAUGHS)
-(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
With-- With the march,
we want everyone to come out,
bring their parents,
bring their kids,
everybody in the nation is
either a child or a former child
and that's what we wanna do,
is say,
"This isn't about red and blue,
this is about
protecting the kids."
-Okay.
-(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
And you also have a boycott,
right, in mind for--
I think that's a great idea.
Yeah, so what we're trying to
do with that is...
we essentially-- We met with
some of the legislators
in Tallahassee and we felt like
we didn't really get far enough
because they wouldn't even
discuss assault weapons there.
What they did discuss though,
was porn
as a public health emergency.
-(CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Which just goes to show you...
It's porn, but...
-A, uh, related shooting issue.
-DAVID: Yeah.
-Yeah.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
But sadly, that's the only one
that these law-makers seemed
to care about.
Right. Is that really...
(LAUGHS)
That's what they said to you?
They said, "Let's switch
the subject to porn"?
-DAVID: Mm-hmm.
-They--
BILL: And how old are you guys?
-Seventeen?
-BOTH: Seventeen.
BILL: Not gonna work with you.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
I remember 17 and, boy,
I didn't--
Well, I say they stop looking
at that stuff
and actually start looking
at our lives, you know?
BILL: Right.
(APPLAUSE)
-So-- So--
-BILL: So-- Yeah.
So, with the economics,
with all of that,
we felt like,
at least I felt like,
we weren't getting
enough movement,
so I decided if the only thing
these politicians care about
is money,
we'll go after their money.
That's very smart.
You know, I gotta say...
(APPLAUSE)
...watching, besides the service
you're doing to the country
about guns...
You know, I don't have kids.
And I only see what I know
about them from television,
I-- I avoid them in life.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-With good reason.
-Yeah.
(BILL CHUCKLES)
But watch--
I mean, you're so together.
And all of you, not just you,
the other people from
your school I've seen on TV:
calm, articulate,
I honestly thought
kids were a lot stupider.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-You have really...
given me faith that the kids
today are actually very bright.
(APPLAUSE)
I-- And I'll tell you why--
Way brighter than we were--
It's only because they locked up
the Tide Pods.
(BILL LAUGHS)
In all seriousness,
I think the good thing--
One of the best things about
our generation, sure,
people think we're lazy
and on our phones all the time
and, sure, you know,
that's me, but we don't--
(BILL LAUGHS)
We don't respect people just
because we have to.
We don't respect you
just because you have "senator"
in front of your name.
-BILL: Right.
-And, Mr. Rubio,
if you don't believe me,
watch, you know, the news.
-And...
-BILL: Right.
We don't just stand for--
We don't let people
steam roll over us.
We have voices and we use them,
sometimes unfortunately,
sometimes for good,
and that's why--
I think you're doing very good.
And I wanna know, how long do--
Do you think you will keep
doing this,
how long will this keep going?
Well,
to be quite frank with you,
we're millennials
and we love complaining
more than any other generation,
so...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-CAMERON: Ask the stage manager.
Could you--
(LAUGHS)
Why, were you bitching about
something here?
No, uh, look,
a lot of people are trying to
take us down quickly,
they're trying to discredit us,
they're trying to say
we don't know
what we're talking about.
Well, until you've been on
the receiving end--
BILL: Some of them even called
you actors.
Well, I am an actor, actually.
-BILL: Oh.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
I'm in Spring Awakening
right now
at the
Barclay Performing Arts Center,
-it's a great show.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
What I'm saying is,
you can say we don't know
what we're talking about
because we're 17 years old,
but until you've been on
the receiving end of an AR-15,
until you've been locked into
your cl--
Look, Wayne LaPierre,
Dana Loesch... (SHUDDERS)
-BILL: Right.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
I don't know--
I don't know if you guys
have ever had to
deal with that,
but as far as I know,
that's not the case.
We've been locked in
a classroom,
we have seen our friends text
their parents goodbye,
we are the experts,
we know exactly
what we're talking about,
how dare you tell us
we don't know what we're--
BILL: I'm friend. Friend!
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Let's, uh, take that again.
(CLAPS)
Cameron, scene two.
Uh... Yes, agreed.
What I'm asking is, like,
in six months, say,
if you haven't gotten
the change you wanted,
you're gonna graduate high
school at some point, right?
Hopefully.
(LAUGHS)
I might not. Um...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
BILL: Would you see doing this
as a career?
Blowing off college.
Because, honestly, guys,
college is a bunch of bullshit.
(AUDIENCE GROANS)
Kidding, kids, kidding,
it's great. Yeah, college.
Uh...
You probably, you know,
would learn more
or just as much, you know,
I mean,
you already have
this great platform.
We'd certainly learn more than
our politicians are--
What they take action on.
BILL: Right. Well, I do think
you're gonna get something done,
I really do.
I mean, we have never quite seen
change like this,
or at least people
receptive to it.
And I think part of the reason
for that is:
we've kept reminding people
that this isn't about us,
this isn't about Democrats
or Republicans,
this is about Americans
and those 17 individuals
that lost their lives that day,
that's what this
should really be about.
CAMERON: We're not targeting
people's guns.
My father's a police officer,
his father's former FBI,
we have guns in our houses,
we're not trying to tear apart
the Second Amendment,
we are just kids begging for
our lives getting murdered
in our classrooms.
But, honestly, I think that's
part of the problem
in this country,
is that nobody goes after
the Second Amendment.
Nothing is really gonna change
unless somebody
talks about that.
The reason why this country
is different is 'cause we
treat guns as a right,
other countries
treat it as a privilege.
And every debate begins,
with even--
(APPLAUSE)
Even the liberal side, uh,
you know,
just bowing down to the
Second Amendment
and I don't know if that's
the right approach.
The Second Amendment is a very,
very good piece
of rhetoric defense
that I've seen a lot,
because they put it as if
we're attacking a right
that you're born with,
and at the end of the day,
a 19-year-old--
BILL: But it is if you're
an American.
If you're an American.
A 19-year-old bought
a weapon that you don't need
to keep robbers and bears
out of your house.
And if that kid had seen
a professional for five minutes
they wouldn't have said,
"You need a gun,"
they would have said,
"You need a councillor."
And that was just
allowed to happen.
-BILL: Okay.
-(APPLAUSE)
So, one of your classmates,
I think her name was Samantha...
and Trump called her and the
first thing he said to her was,
"I heard you're a big fan."
(LAUGHS)
That sounds about right.
I didn't even know about that,
-but that sounds about right.
-BILL: Oh, really?
Do you know
who I'm talking about?
-I think so.
-BILL: Yeah.
And she said,
"I was never so unimpressed
with someone in my life."
(APPLAUSE)
Yeah, I actually hung up on
the White House the other day.
BILL:
You hung up on the White House?
Yeah, because they called us
the day before--
BILL: Surprised you got through.
-Well, no, they called me.
-BILL: Oh.
They actually called me the day
before the listening session
and asked if
we were going to come.
And I said,
"I'm not coming because we
expect President Trump
to come to the CNN town hall,"
which he never declined
an invitation from,
and the fact that they called us
the day before,
I found very offensive,
considering the fact that there
are funerals the next day,
there's mourning
we still had to do.
And I ended on this message with
them, I said,
"President Trump-- We don't need
to listen to President Trump,
President Trump needs to listen
to the screams of the children
and the screams of this nation."
(APPLAUSE)
Well, listen,
I want you to know something
about President Trump
because you haven't been around
long enough
to see a lot of presidents,
who's the first one
you remember, Bush?
I was at my first Obama rally
when I was seven-years-old.
Seven-years-old, so you don't
even remember Bush hardly!
I remember hearing
a lot about Bush.
-BILL: Yeah.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
I'm sure all good.
Anyway, uh...
But Bush, Obama, Clinton,
they all go in one basket,
I, you know, happen to fall
with the Democrats usually,
-but... (LAUGHS)
-DAVID: Shock.
Surprising.
But they're all in one kettle,
and then there's this...
thing that happened,
-this virus from outer space...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...that took over.
I just want you to know how much
this is not like anything that's
ever, ever,
ever happened before,
and hopefully will not be
in your future.
And I mean this sincerely,
I really do,
to all of the generations
before us,
we sincerely accept
your apology.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-And we appreciate that you are
willing to let us rebuild the
world that you fucked up.
(CHEERING)
Good luck trying.
(CHUCKLES)
I mean it.
Thanks for doing
what you're doing.
-Thank you.
-All right, David and Cameron.